Well, we're going to get jump right in with answering these questions that we have come in so reminders to you make sure you're looking at the members only site to see all the announcements we have some announcements that we've been talking about for months now starting January first we're going to drop back to one zoom call per week.
Well, actually, we're actually going to be adding another zoom call that we're dropping this Monday zoom call. So they will no longer zoom call unless you guys decide that you want the protocol zoom call to be Monday at food. So we're adding this protocol zoom call.
We probably will do that weekly or maybe every other week. I haven't decided yet, but we're going to add a protocol zoom call to go over protocols since we can't be doing cheek swabs anymore. Please look at the member site for details on that.
I guess I didn't make a slide about that too. So we're going to have a protocol zoom call. Please send in your preferred might not get what you want, but I'm going to kind of take a.
Kind of like a little survey and when you want to have that, you know, maybe Monday. I do it is a horrible time for people. We're not getting real good participation. So maybe we want to do it at a different time. Maybe Monday evening or something like that. So put your.
Send in your via the zoom call questions blue box on the member site.
Send in your preferred time and day of the week to do that. So yes, we are going to be doing cheek swabs anymore because the state won't allow us to do those and we're not going to be doing one of one calls anymore.
Because the power is that we are just getting worse and worse and there's not a lot of ways to do those things.
So everything's got to be done over the zoom. Well, anyway, it started with us. The last year that was really your plan to anyhow.
But now we just have to really enforce it. So it's just the legal things. The state medical boards are very actively attacking clinics like ours.
And they are now requiring that we have no one on one visits. This is listed. I just took this right off the member site. So please look at these updates right on the member site.
So I'm not going to read this. You can read this later on the member site.
So remember reminder that you have all have access to all our courses using your same user name and password.
Okay, some questions that came in.
I was originally diagnosed with pancreatic cancer. Now I have a new diagnosis and squamous cell cancer.
Is there a daytime program on my right for my squamous cell cancer? Can I use the current one?
Or is there a specific ball required? Are there any topicals or supplements that would be a better option than those surgery?
So let's go back to the first question. Originally diagnosed with pancreatic question, cancer. Now I have squamous cell cancer. So that's totally different cancer and totally different frequencies.
So I'll look up who asked this question.
And I will send you a flash drive with some daytime programs that you can use for your squamous cell cancer. So I, this is this is a perfect example of a person need to update on their program.
So, you know, we've said time and time again that oh, I was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer. Now they're saying I have metastasis to the liver. Do I need a different program? Well, no, it's still pancreatic cancer in the liver.
Or I was diagnosed with prostate cancer. Now they're saying I have metastasis to the bone. Do I need a different program? Well, no, you know, it's still prostate cancer in the bone.
But this is a completely different cancer. So when there's a completely different cancer, you want to be running the frequencies for that cancer. So I'll need to send you a flash drive with some daytime programs for squamous cell cancer.
So it's a very good question.
That's part of the question. Can I use should I use a different bulb? No, use the same bulb. You have don't make any changes there.
So just use the same bulb. Then the last part of the question. Are there any topicals or supplements that would be better option than the most surgery? Well, there's nothing that's going to replace the most surgery for squamous cell.
So, but people have used different topicals for squamous cell cancer. Probably the most common topical for squamous cell cancer are different, just simply a said different essential oils.
So essential oils can be really helpful for basil and squamous cell. So a regular oil is probably one of the more common essential oils to use for squamous or basil cell.
Also, frankincense, papayma, lemon grass, you might have to make sure when you're doing a top when you're doing a topical essential oil, you got to just make sure you don't get too much skin irritation. Some people don't get any.
And I would just use like a drop of it there just to drop on your finger then put it on the cancer itself.
One of these things are going to be a substitute for a mobile surgery in the eyes of the medical profession. So you're, but certainly it's something that you can add.
Right. Next question. Please let me know if you're able to address this question and I will make a point to join. Okay, I didn't tell this person beforehand. Sorry. Monday or Wednesday, both were understand that it'll be whatever you said in a question will be on the next Zoom call.
So this person will have to listen to this one. I was recently acquainted with an anthropotic doctor who is skeptical about the right machine. Well, welcome to the, the team of skeptical people on the right machine. There's a lot of doctors that are skeptical about the right machine.
A lot of doctors are skeptical about things that you still know what he's doing to summarize. He said, if the exact frequency of the particular cancer stone, which is likely due to mutation, it won't do anything. Well, I would agree. That's why the way we write programs is we put sweet programs in there. So as a cancer cell mutates, you know, we'll still hit that.
And there's no absolute perfect way to get the frequency of the cancer. It's just impossible.
So you just do your best. And that's the beauty of having eight hours every night that I can write programming for the chance that we're going to hit that frequency is pretty darn good.
You know, again, I've shared with you in the different times of my practice when we used to have people come in the office years and years ago.
And they had take granted cancer and they are only my office three hours a week. Well, it's like crazy.
Like how do I know I'm hitting the right frequency, getting only 180 minutes a week, three hours a week in programming.
It's a big difference between three hours a week in programming and writing eight or nine hours a night.
So the chance of us hitting that frequency is very is much better.
So I think I answered that.
One styrofoam piece inside the right bulb slowly shifted until it was in the middle.
So my husband opened the side and pulled it back with some tweezers.
Now when I turned on a rife setting, it's way louder than before that the red lights and the red light blinks on the right side where it says ball.
Well, as behind the red on off switch, the sounds are coming from the machine, Dr. Ball, I'm almost afraid it sounds like I'd be electrocuted or something.
So I've shut it off and I've used it most nights.
Okay, so if something happened where he hit the solder, where the where the electric line goes into the bulb itself, that's probably what happened.
So I would you just need to send the bulb back to make it true right you need to set it back to true right.
Go to true right.com, get their address, you can call them tell them, you know, you know, you're got the right from us and you just need a bulb repair.
You really inexpensive they'll check it out. They'll do a thorough check on it and get you the bulb back.
So definitely you do not want to play with it yourself. You do not want to.
First of all, you should never even have done that.
Not to scold you, but there's there's nothing wrong with the frequencies will go right through the phone. So I don't care if the phone slides in or not.
That's really meaningless. Don't open up your bulb for really any reason, you should not be opening up your bulb for any reason.
There's just too many things that could happen if you hit the solder, it's a special type of solder, you should not be trying to do that yourself at all.
So you set it in two to right and they'll repair that.
Since I've been at it, this is the same person asking this question, I just split it into two questions to get out of the slides.
For four years now, haven't seen any tumor shrinkage. I wonder if it's actually supposed to be this way, meaning that we've talked about so many times that as long as it's not growing, it's not technically quote unquote cancer.
Because cancer is by definition, cells that are at rapid replication. So yes, you might be exactly right.
Are you talking about the right fear as it's supposed to be more quiet, could be more dangerous. I should ever see it again.
If you like or call true right and talk to Jake there or anybody who answers the phone, tell them you just need to get the bulb repaired. They're really fast. If you ship it to them, they'll get it done in one day and ship it back to you.
It's really very efficient. So I wouldn't worry about that. Always, whatever you have any type of bulb issue or machine issue, you want to just get it to them to get it corrected correctly.
Years ago, I had a patient who was doing it was given really three months to live and after a year, he was doing fantastic. A matter of fact, there's oncologist.
I asked him to come in the office and he had no problem because I want to know everything you're doing. He was writing it down. Of course, he wasn't writing it down for his patients because you can't recommend anything to his patients. He's probably writing it down for him as family.
But you really, you really like to see honest other practitioners like that.
But unfortunately, this person passed away several months later and his wife contacted me and said, he was doing great, doing the right every day, every night.
But then he retrieved on the bulb wire and it pulled the wire out of the bulb and I told him to ship it back to right to get it fixed and he refused. He soldered it himself and it never worked the same since then.
It sent us the machine and the bulb back. I sent it directly to Mike and he said that this just wasn't working. None of the frequencies were coming through the bulb because you use the wrong sorrow.
So you don't want to do things yourself literally, it cost me $35 to have that bulb fixed. This is not an expensive fix of these machines.
So don't try to do that yourself. Just send it into them or contact them and they'll let you know the steps to do.
All right, we don't have any other chat questions come in. I do a lot of people jumped on the call here after I got through this.
In January, we're going to add up protocol, zoom call protocol, zoom call, we're just going to talk about protocols, just talk about supplements and supplements and diet of this protocol, zoom call, we're dropping the Monday, zoom call.
This is the last Monday, zoom call because next Monday, we're not going to be open. So this is the last Monday, zoom call, and then we're going to add a protocol, zoom call, but I want you guys to pick the day and the time you want it because these Monday, dude, zoom calls are not very well attended.
So I'm assuming that it's just probably not a good time for a lot of you. Of course, people that are out here, it's probably a good time. But if you're listening to this later, it's probably not a good time for you.
But you guys to give me some suggestions that you want to have that protocol, zoom call, whether it be getting the evening or even later in the evening, I won't put it there. I want to take care of you guys and serve you.
So, especially some of the things that the state boards are doing to us, they're just shutting us down as far as being able to do one on one calls and I explain that completely on the members only site, so go to the members only site.
So you can see what I've written about what's going on with the state boards coming after us. So, okay, we'll abide by their rules and we'll be able to stay in business, but we've got to do this all over group zoom calls everything's got to be over group zoom call.
So, give me some times that work for you guys.
Did you get the zoom call questions that you just submitted? Oh, let's look and see.
So, here comes the question and see if we could call that up.
Alright, so the question is in the past month, my skin, entire body and scalp have become very sensitive also when I walk, I consider will pay to my feet.
My feet and ankles are slightly swollen again. Yesterday on the right, I ran to the immune support, swelling and liver support.
I have no energy and I'm tired. I have had a busy schedule, not physical, but stuff going on and the people visiting me periodically, I still try to get an amp in two or three times a day, but I get up to three times a night to change the bandage.
The tumor is, so I'm going to address that first part, wasn't really a question, but you said you're getting skin and entire body scalp and become sensitive.
So, what could be the possibility of skin and scalp sensitive? Well, because of your tumor is, is, is exposed beyond your body, it could be skin stretching neurological sensitivity, maybe yes.
Those things are possible.
I don't know why your scalp would be sensitive, not sure about that.
And I don't know with what you have going on, what it would cause you to your feet, though, except just the swelling is the limb detoxification.
So, I think you're really right on the right support on the idea of doing the swelling and liver support, just helping with detox for sure.
The tumor is purging a lot, more gray sluggy dead cells, lots of fluid in the past week by bad, is there a change every two to three hours.
I'm eating three meals per day, and I have been for a couple of weeks in the past two weeks, I only lost, is it six pounds?
Or is it point six, you have point six pounds, hopefully it's only point six pounds, whether the month prior, I was losing two to three pounds a week.
So, that would be really good news. So, that's really good news if that, if that weight loss has stopped, tell you that is a huge plus right there.
Last week, I had a vitamin C IV and had been wearing more patches, those ice wave patches under the guidance of the doctor who's very well first in the patches.
Chris was very Christmas to you, as well, I'm praying for you guys.
I just want to give you some encouragement if that is you've only lost point six pounds in the last two weeks, that's a big plus.
Make sure you keep eating, and hopefully you're that stuff that's that you're purging out of that tumor is just dead cells, more and more dead cells, that's just fantastic.
So, keep up the good work.
I have a question on the zoo on the chat, I haven't used it if there are some sort of for three weeks now I'm experiencing a huge amount of swelling though in my right breast where the cancer's located any thoughts as to why that might be happening.
Maybe the soda is increasing heat, so you're increasing heat, you're increasing inflammation and the whole idea is the inflammation you're increasing is an immune response that's going to help kill the cancer.
Some people can increase swelling with the soda to that could be a problem, but what a back off on it a little bit see if that makes a difference and you could either back off of the number of sessions and just back off of the time.
Try that.
I think it's worth a try.
All right, so get in your times that you want to do the protocol zoom call.
Please make sure you look at all the updates on the members only site, look at the new restrictions that they're requiring for us.
We could get mad, we could be all upset, we could scream and raise a fit or we could go, okay, God's going to use this to be able to help us help more people and that's the way we're looking at it.
We trust that God's sovereignty is good at all things and that all those that are called according to his purpose, he has a plan for and we can trust his love and great.
And game for us so that's what we're looking for.
Obviously, everything we look at is got an internal perspective that's what we're called to do.
And so we look at the journal perspective with everything that happens to pray that he's in control, we trust in his perfect plan for us and for you know that we're praying for all of you and we love you all deeply.
And I'll talk to you in a couple days.